life is poker not chess as Annie Duke
she's a former professional poker player
who won over four million dollars in
major tournaments before retiring her
new book is called thinking and bets
making smarter decisions when you don't
have all the facts and it draws on her
experience at the poker table while also
synthesizing all sorts of leading-edge
research from social psychology
evolutionary economics and game theory
reason sat down with her recently at our
New York studios let's think about the
difference between a game of poker and a
game of chess so a game of chess you can
see all the pieces right so I know your
whole position and there's very little
luck involved the quality of the outcome
that you have from playing chess is very
very tightly tied to the quality of the
decision-making in the chess game in
other words I know that if you generally
are making worse decisions then than I
am as we play that you will lose and I
will win life is more like poker because
we don't have the facts we don't have
perfect knowledge we don't even know
what the you know what other people are
holding correct and this is the really
important thing outcomes and decision
quality and poker are very sort of
pulled apart they're very loosely tied
but this is probably a good moment to
bring up the Pete Carroll example right
so it's the coach of the Seattle
Seahawks in the Superbowl he called a
play that worked out poorly the Seahawks
lost and everybody was like what an
idiot but you actually defend him in I
think that this is a really good example
of this thing that makes poker a better
model for decision-making in general so
in poker I can have the best hand and I
can lose I can have the worst hand and I
can win just because of the luck of the
draw so we can think about that in terms
of this Pete Carroll situation and we
can compare it to this really
interesting play that happened in the
Super Bowl just now with the Eagles and
the Patriots also because the Patriots
are always in the Super Bowl that's
right thankfully they lost us yes I'm
well I'm from Philadelphia so yes indeed
thankfully 26 seconds left in the game
the Seattle Seahawks are on the one-yard
line of the New England Patriots they
only have one timeout left it
second down everybody is expecting a
handoff to Marshawn Lynch one of the
greatest running backs of all time
boom plow it through if he doesn't
they'll call the timeout hand it off to
him again plow it through instead what
Pete Carroll does is he calls for a pass
play Russell Wilson passes the ball and
notoriously we all know it was
intercepted by Malcom Butler end of the
game
so obviously the headlines were not kind
to Pete Carroll but let's do the thought
experiment right so let's imagine that
he calls that play and the pass is
caught then what do the headlines look
like brilliant he outsmarted Belichick
in fact because of the Super Bowl that
just happened we don't need to do that
thought experiment anymore
because we have the Philadelphia Eagles
on the one-yard line
it's fourth and one everybody's
expecting them to go for a field goal
instead they decide to go for it they do
this crazy thing where Nick Foles steps
out of the quarterback position he runs
into the end zone he catches the ball
and it's oh my gosh outsmarted Belichick
but either of those two plays are not
brilliant based just on whether they
worked out on that one time that would
be like saying if I flip a coin and you
call it heads and it lands heads that
you're brilliant right so the issue here
is what you really want to do is dig
down into the math of whether that play
was actually correct right and you point
out that it was a smart decision but the
results were not good the interception
rate in that spot was only about one or
two percent so it's this time management
the clock management problem so if they
hand it off to Marshawn Lynch they're
only going to get two tries at the end
zone assuming the first one doesn't work
if they pass it it's if it's caught they
win if it's dropped the clock stops and
they don't use one of their timeouts and
they'll actually still have enough time
on the clock to run the exact same two
so people in finance will really
understand this it's almost a free
option do you think Pete Carroll and I
realize you're not a psychologist but do
you think he's like now I was absolutely
it was the right decision so I don't
need to be a psychologist to know
because he said so so he was on The
Today Show the experts not just average
joes say it was the worst call ever
there was the worst result of a call
ever the call would have been a great
one if we
catch it and would have been just fine
and nobody would have thought twice
about it so Pete Carril really got that
this was a resulting problem and I think
that what's interesting is that now
we're seeing the headlines on this you
know fools play it's not for nothing
right like I mean this is something we
can just sort of look at and say haha
look at that two totally different
reactions except that we go around and
we change our decision-making because
we've evaluated the quality of decision
based on one outcome so as people look
at you know should you pass in that spot
because it didn't work out in 2015 you
know people are gonna change their their
decision behavior because of that result
so maybe they're gonna you know now go
for it more because of it well and that
you know in a real life situation
because say it's you're getting married
or you're investing or you're buying
this house versus the other these are
events that you're not hopefully not
going to do more than you know say it
doesn't I'm in a lifetime like you don't
have that big a dataset right so how do
you adapt you know not not being too
swayed by the results from the quality
of the decision make it so this is
actually one of the really big problems
is that for most of the kinds of
decisions that we make in life we have
this hidden information problem right
there's this big element of luck issue
and in general most of the decisions
that we have we can't collect enough
outcomes for the data to be super
meaningful so I think the way that I put
it in the book is we're generally
dealing with like four coin flips not
ten thousand so what are you supposed to
do in that situation and what I argue is
that analyze the decision quality based
on these kinds of sort of the same way
that you would analyze the Pete Carril
decision and try to cordon your self off
from the outcome in other words be a
really big information gatherer and get
as much information so that your beliefs
are as well informed as possible that's
number one to being a really good
decision maker and solving for this
problem right make sure that you are
entertaining views that disagree with
you in order to calibrate those
decisions really well those are the most
valuable news yeah um and the last thing
is as you're trying to think about the
future be a really good scenario planner
get them real
good lay of the landscape recognize the
uncertainty in the future don't say I
know it will work out this way because
that will close your mind off to all the
other possible ways that it could work
out and once you've figured out well
here are the sort of set of ways that I
think it can work out let me take a stab
at the probabilities and once you do
that now as you have one of the
particular types of futures turnout you
don't get overly attached to it instead
you use it as a way to tweak right as
opposed to some really big signal to
create a huge shift in in whatever your
underlying beliefs are well and one of
one of the focuses of the book is about
surrounding yourself with a good group
of people who you know aren't yes-men I
mean so again it's a business situation
but also in your personal life you want
people who give you real feedback or
meaningful feedback heterodox feedback
one of the things that you talked about
that I thought was really interesting is
the difference between exploratory
thought and confirmatory thought I
highly recommend people to look at fill
telex work and this is really where a
lot of this is coming from and he talks
about these two styles of thoughts that
you can get out of groups so I think
that we generally think that group
decision-making is better than
individual decision-making this is the
wisdom of the crowd yeah the wisdom of
the crowd kind of thing so just get a
group together make decisions together
you all be better off and that's
actually not true it depends on the what
something about the group and it's
exactly what you just said does the
group have a confirmatory thinking style
or an exploratory thinking style so a
confirmatory thinking style is that
we're all affirming each other's beliefs
right that's sort of what we generally
think of as an echo chamber and by the
way it's where we like to be so the
problem is that groups tend to drift off
into this confirmatory style what we'd
really like to promote as an exploratory
style so we can think of an expense
between the group trying to be right
versus the group trying to be accurate a
group that's goal is to be right this is
going to be one with a confirmatory
style is their goal is to affirm that
the beliefs that they have are right
that's the goal in other words whatever
I believe before I would like to know
that that was the right thing to believe
a group whose goal is accuracy is
actually gonna have a very different
goal in mind which is it's not about
making sure that my prior is that
whatever I believed before is right but
making sure that the things that I
believe are as good a representation of
the objective truth as possible so it
sounds a little like well what sitting
right and accurate but it's a really
really deep distinction and once you
have a group who's committed to accuracy
now you naturally are going to develop
an exploratory thought style because in
order to have accurate beliefs you have
to be hungry for information and what
kind of information do you have to be
particularly hungry for information that
dissents would the prevailing view in
the group well you know that's an
uncomfortable process because we know
the answers and we just want to do the
math to get to show we're right but on
an individual level how do you build up
the resiliency to put yourself out there
to say okay this is what I think is true
or this is what I want to be true but
then make sure that you're actually
going through the process to find out
whether or not it really is true being
wrong is painful right I mean our
natural tendency as human beings is this
tendency toward right versus accurate
right and we've made that distinction so
we like to think that our beliefs are
true we like to think that good things
that happen or to our credit and bad
things that happen are in our fault and
you know that were intelligent and smart
and well-informed individuals and if you
tell me something that completely
disagrees with me that that our natural
instinct is to feel threatened by that
and to feel challenged by it so I'll
tend to try to swat it away and the
reason for that really comes back to you
know something Kahneman really I think
said very well in Thinking Fast and Slow
which is that we want the narrative our
lives to be positive as we think back on
it we want this positive narrative and
so sort of being you know being right
fits into that you know oh I did a
really good job or that thing wasn't my
fault that all helps that narrative
along so the question is how do you get
that narrative to come together to
maintain that positive narrative but
have it come together with this more
exploratory style
this this better focus on your beliefs
being accurate you know in the objective
sense and it's through the group right
so you go you go find some people who
are committed to the same mission and
now just like yeah you know we've all
heard about Pavlov in the Bell right
like he rings a bell and the dogs are
salivating and they're getting this
reward that goes along with it or a rat
in a skinner box you know he finishes
the maze and you give him a pellet and
the a the rat is happy that the group
can act to reinforce this exploratory
style through two mechanisms one is not
to reward the more confirmatory style of
thinking and to give you all of that
really wonderful social approval from
the exploratory this style of thinking
so the best example I can give you of
this is a conversation that I had with
Eric Seidel that has stuck with me this
was look super early in my career I
remember going up to Eric who is one of
the greatest players ever I think that
his total tournament earnings are
something like 38 million dollars yes
yeah ballpark right this is a really
great player so I went up to him and I
was like I can't believe this I got that
so unlucky this guy played so bad and I
played so much better than he did and
blahblahblah and I was you know Mona
Mona Mona Mona Mona and I have never had
such a blunt and bad reaction to
something I have said to him and this is
someone I admired I really wanted to be
his peer and what he said to me was why
are you telling me this story like if it
was just bad luck like literally there's
nothing to you know be learned from it
and by the way I've lost a lot of hands
too and I've heard a lot of what we call
Bad Beat stories that's what I was
telling him I've heard so many bad Bates
stories and honestly I just don't care
now if you have a question about the
hand if you want to talk about strategy
if you're looking for my opinion on how
you could have done better
be my guest so I think that that
statement from him sums up really
perfectly how do you get this kind of
thinking going well I wanted his social
approval so now as I go to interact with
him in the future what kinds of things
am I gonna want to be telling him I'm
gonna want to tell him hey I think I
made a mistake why because he's gonna
give me a pellet for that in the
form of engagement in the form of saying
wow that's really great that you
admitted that I think that's amazing
here's my perspective and as I'm open
minded to us his perspective as I'm not
swatting that away he's giving me all of
this reinforcement for that what is he
not reinforcing confirmatory style
thought and so now it's like you get to
have your cake and eat it too right you
get to be an exploratory thinker but
also still feel really good about
yourself I also feel like you have a
positive narrative because you've you've
changed the way that I like to put it
maybe because I'm a poker players you've
changed the definition of what it means
to win is there a politics or an
ideology embedded in the way you're
talking about stuff because one of the
things in contemporary America now we
talk a lot about echo chambers and that
you know partly and it's good overall
but you know people people can retreat
to vast endless storehouses of people
who will confirm everything that you
already believe whether it's MSNBC or
Fox News or you know the New York Times
versus the Washington Times or something
like that and what you're talking about
it strikes me as very much of a kind of
enlightenment for you of let the truth
you know we're never going to get there
so in a way it's kind of a postmodern
enlightenment we're not we're never
going to know all the facts we're never
going to know everything but we can
approximate it by you know swearing
allegiance to finding out what is true
rather than what is convenient and it
sounded a lot to me in reading your book
some of it like Friedrich Hayek's
thought which really and Karl Popper
emphasizing the limits of knowledge and
then how do you get a little bit smarter
and how are you disinterested so that
you are actually you know moving forward
and and getting closer to truth or
progress is that am i off there or is is
there an ad you have an ideology or a
politics behind all of this I would say
that for me it's more of the politics of
constructive dissent so take your choice
but what I think is that these echo
chambers that we get whether it's the
echo chamber of you know Democrats or
the echo chamber of Republicans you know
where it's all about yes yes yes we're
right and the other side is bad I don't
think it's good for our society I don't
think it's good for our palate
for sure I don't think it bodes well for
the state of the union so if I think
that regardless of whether you lean
democrat you lean Republican you lean
classic liberal whatever it might be
whatever your party identity is let's
have it not be the overriding identity
so that you're willing to override your
principles override the fact of the
matter close your mind off to what the
other side has to say I kind of go back
to again I go back to John Stuart Mill a
lot on this shot through the book he is
shot through the book because I would
like everybody to read on Liberty please
there you go
please everybody go read that book read
it before mine or after I guess I should
say read it after mind of what by them
together by them together a damn right
so um so here's the thing when we've
descended into an echo chamber of only
listening to the opinions that affirm us
because we are so sure that we are right
what happens in that situation is that
whatever your truth is has atrophied
like even if the even if that is
actually the objective truth your
inability to be able to defend it
against somebody who has a rationale and
we I'm not talking about people who are
just like yelling you're dumb right but
people who have a rational reasonable
explanation for why they hold an
opposing viewpoint you need to be able
to debate that effectively I think so
and and this is John Stuart Mill says
it's even if something is a hundred
percent true you better be able to
defend that against somebody who
believes something differently so for
example I happen to believe the earth is
round but if I can't debate that
effectively against a flat earther it's
somewhat meaningless that I believe that
the earth is round and when we descend
into these political echo chambers I
think that we're descending into that
problem sure okay
the earth is round but you can no longer
defend it against the flat earthers so
what does it mean that that you believe
that anymore
I think it completely loses its meaning
and I would argue that one of the things
that happens when you force yourself to
be able to defend it against the
rational actor
who hold different opinions is that you
very often find out that your belief
needs a little bit of calibration and
that's good for all of us right I mean
when I say oh you disagree with me if my
identity is no longer about being right
but it's about being someone who's
searching for the most accurate
objective truth of the matter because
you disagree with me I no longer view
you as an enemy I view as someone who
can really help me even though we
disagree you can now be really helpful
either because you moderate my opinion
or because you make me better at
understanding why I have that opinion in
the first place and either of those is
good well we will leave it there thank
you so much we've been talking with
Annie Duke she's the author most
recently of thinking in bets making
smarter decisions when you don't have
all the facts thanks so much thank you
for reason I'm Nikolas be
[Music]
you
[Music]